let's go back to the phones a lot of
people who want to check in with me
today at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our caller from the 2 3 4
area code Tyler from 2 3 4 definitely
make sure we're off speakerphone and
who's whose yep I didn't know the break
would be so short anyway my name is I'm
I'm from Ohio and I just have a pretty
unrelated question but my question is I
didn't know you were a drummer what do
you enjoy about drumming how often do
you practice have you ever been in a
band or released anything
I've never let's see have I release
stuff I guess I have I've been in a
couple bands and we played shows I was
in one band in western Massachusetts I
was in another band in Brooklyn when I
lived there I have not found a band in
Boston yet I tried out with one band
wasn't really a good fit and you know
it's not that I don't have enough to do
but I just have not found a band to play
with here in Boston but I would love to
do that what do I love about drumming I
don't know it's just uh it's both fun
and interesting mentally and the
coordination of forelimbs
I feel like connects areas of my brain
in ways that other stuff doesn't yeah I
don't know I've just enjoyed it for the
15 years I played okay cool just because
I'm also a drummer so it was cool find
out that we also all right or some
favorite drummers that's a good question
I don't know I like a lot um just for
the technicality of it like a lot of the
progressive metal drummers but also
there's some really excellent math rock
drummers so I've done Damon Damon che
I'm not sure if that's how you pronounce
it hmm and Zach Hill is also he's in the
band hella there right now he's in Death
Grips he's pretty crazy too but yeah oh
man I think the only overlap would that
I have is I used to like Dream Theater
when Mike Portnoy was the drummer but
beyond exactly I think he think I think
he's a great drummer he's very talented
what he does yeah but what about like
Steve Gadd and Vinnie Colaiuta and those
guys I have nothing but respect for sure
I mean I mean I can only do so much
myself so I mean I always look up to
people were able to move as quickly and
with such textareas they all right if
you were to badmouth Steve Gadd we would
have to put you in our call system as
never pick up on again but we're not
going to do that okay
everything for the call appreciate it
yep that's we're checking in always good
to hear from other drummers